DAVID TU: Hey, this is David Tu.
And in this video, I'll be
walking through new launches
for monitoring and telemetry.
Stick around to learn about
Service Directory and Network
Intelligence Center.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First off is something I'm
really excited to share.
Service Directory provides a
managed runtime service catalog
that allows all of a
customer's services
to be accessed from a
single pane of glass
across Google Cloud, on-prem,
and hybrid environments.
With Service Directory,
you have the ability
to look up services.
Services can use Service
Directory to look each other up
by name, instead
of needing to know
infrastructure-level
details, like IP addresses.
Service Directory can be
queried via HTTP, GRPC, and DNS.
Service Directory also
gives you the ability
to catalog services.
Developers can annotate and
search for custom properties
on their services.
For example, if I'm trying to
make a service GDPR-compliant,
I might also want to use
this information dynamically
to have the service
only be allowed
to communicate with other
GDPR-compliant services.
Now instead of having multiple
Google Cloud APIs determining
which service is
GDPR-compliant, an admin
can easily identify
all the services
that are GDPR-compliant with
the Service Directory API.
To recap, Service Directory
provides a single pane of glass
that discovers, registers,
and catalogs your services
for easy management.
The next topic for
monitoring and telemetry
is the Network
Intelligence Center.
Network Intelligence Center
provides a single console
for managing Google Cloud
network visibility, monitoring,
and troubleshooting.
There are currently four modules
to the Network Intelligence
Center--
Network Topology, Connectivity
Test, Performance Dashboard,
and Firewall Insights.
Today, we'll cover Network
Topology and Connectivity Test.
For starters, Network Topology
is a visualization tool
for viewing the topology
of your VPC networks
and the metrics that are
associated with your Google
Cloud resources.
Network Topology shows
actual traffic flows
between various
networking nodes,
including Google Cloud
workloads and network services,
like load balancers
and external clients,
and associated
performance metrics.
One thing I'm
particularly excited about
is the ability to view your
infrastructure changes.
You can look at
topology evolution
and its associated metrics
for six weeks of history.
This interactive
visualization of the topology
helps reduce the time spent
to monitor and troubleshoot
workflows.
It also helps you optimize
your architecture for better
performance and/or cost.
Continuing on with the
Network Intelligence Center,
we'll now cover an addition
to the Connectivity Test.
As a refresher,
Connectivity Test
is a configuration
and route analyzer
that lets you diagnose
connectivity issues in your VPC
network due to misconfiguration
or due to missing routes.
When analyzing network
configurations,
Connectivity Test uses
an abstract state machine
to model how a VPC network
should process packets.
Google Cloud
processes the packet
in several logical steps.
With this launch,
Connectivity Test
can take into account the newly
launched hierarchical firewall
policy rules, in addition to
the previous VPC firewall rules.
For context, hierarchical
firewall policies
provide you the ability
to create firewall rules,
not only at the VPC, but at the
folder and organization level.
The Connectivity Test
starts by checking
the hierarchical
firewall policy.
If connectivity is blocked by
a hierarchical firewall policy
rule, the trace includes
the name of the policy.
If the connectivity is blocked
by a VPC firewall rule,
the trace lists the name of
the relevant ingress or egress
firewall rule.
So this concludes our updates
on monitoring and telemetry.
Make sure to check
out the links below
to get additional details
on these new features.
Join us again next time to learn
"What's new in Networking."
[MUSIC PLAYING]